Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Party! Party! You hear the chant at concerts, rising like a tribal rallying cry on a shrill wave of whistles and hard-beaten tambourines. It's at once a call to get down and party, a statement that there's a party going on
感谢收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。想要获取每周的加更节目、无广告收听体验、抢先收听系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。派对！派对！你在音乐会上听到这样的呼喊，它像部落的集结号一样，伴随着尖锐的哨声和猛烈的铃鼓声此起彼伏。这既是一种让人沉浸其中、尽情狂欢的号召，也是一种宣告——派对正在进行。
and an indication that discotheques where the chant originated are back in force. In the last year, they've returned not only as a rapidly spreading social phenomenon via juice bars, after-hours clubs, private lofts open on weekends to members only, floating groups of party givers who take over the ballrooms of old hotels from midnight to dawn, but as a strong influence on the music people listen to and buy. The best discotheque DJs are underground stars, discovering previously ignored albums, foreign imports, album cuts and obscure singles with the power to make the crowd scream
同时也表明，这种呼喊的发源地——迪斯科舞厅——正卷土重来。在过去的一年里，它们不仅通过果汁吧、深夜俱乐部、周末仅对会员开放的私人阁楼、以及从午夜到黎明接管老式酒店宴会厅的流动派对组织，成为一种迅速蔓延的社会现象，而且对人们聆听和购买的音乐产生了强大的影响。最优秀的迪斯科DJ是地下明星，他们发掘出以前被忽视的专辑、外国进口唱片、专辑曲目和冷门单曲，并有能力让全场尖叫。
and playing them overlapped non-stop so you dance until you drop so that dominic was um vince alaci writing an article headlined discotheque rock in rolling stone that edition came out on the 13th of september 1973 and as you will know because I'm reading your notes this is the first mention of disco and it's the article that gave it its name. And never has it been read Tom
他们将这些音乐无缝衔接、循环播放，让你跳到精疲力竭。多米尼克，刚才那是文斯·阿拉西（Vince Alaci）在《滚石》杂志上发表的一篇题为《迪斯科摇滚》（Discotheque Rock）的文章。那一期出版于1973年9月13日。正如你所知——因为我正在读你的笔记——这是迪斯科一词的首次出现，正是这篇文章赋予了它这个名字。汤姆，从来没有人读过它。
with such extraordinary gusto in such a simultaneously unsettling and yet rousing voice I think because there can be a few people who listen to that who aren't seized with the urge to go out and party. Yeah, party.
读得如此兴致勃勃，声音既让人不安又令人振奋。我想，听过这段话的人，很少有人不会产生出去狂欢的冲动。没错，派对。
Yeah. I have no idea what Vince Salaci sounded like. No. But I like to think that he sounded like Iggy Pop. Yes, right. Basically, I was doing him as Iggy Pop. He's a big fan of the Roman Empire, of Edward Gibbon. Isn't he Iggy Pop?
是的。我不知道文斯·萨拉西（Vince Salaci）的声音是什么样的。不知道。但我喜欢想象他的声音像伊基·波普（Iggy Pop）。没错，确实。基本上，我刚才是在模仿伊基·波普。他是罗马帝国和爱德华·吉本（Edward Gibbon）的超级粉丝。他不是伊基·波普吗？
Yes, he is. Yeah, so he thinks about the Roman Empire lots. He definitely does. Yeah. He definitely does. Yeah. He definitely does. So people will have picked up from that that today's theme is disco. It is disco. And in a way, it's a companion piece to our previous episode on the space race,
是的，他是。所以他经常思考罗马帝国。他绝对是这样。他确实如此。他确实如此。他确实如此。所以大家应该已经听出来了，今天的主题是迪斯科。就是迪斯科。在某种程度上，它是我们上一期关于太空竞赛节目的姊妹篇。
Man on the Moon, because this is what's going on in America down on the streets while the Apollo missions are going up. Well, the Apollo missions end in about 1972, don't they? So disco is brewing. It hasn't gone mainstream. Well, the Apollo missions end in about 1972, don't they? So disco is brewing. It hasn't gone mainstream. Yeah, but it's still underground. It's brewing. It's underground in Hell's Kitchen in Soho in Manhattan.
《月球上的人》（Man on the Moon），因为这就是当阿波罗任务在天空中进行时，美国街头正在发生的事情。嗯，阿波罗任务大约在1972年结束，对吧？所以迪斯科正在酝酿中。它还没有成为主流。嗯，阿波罗任务大约在1972年结束，对吧？所以迪斯科正在酝酿中。它还没有成为主流。是的，但它仍然处于地下状态。它正在酝酿。它在曼哈顿苏豪区（Soho）的地狱厨房（Hell's Kitchen）里处于地下状态。
And it's poised, Tom, to explode onto the national scene in the United States. And then, of course, to go around the world, to go global. And of all the subjects we've done on The Rest is History, History's Top Monkeys, History's Greatest Eunuchs, global and of all the subjects we've done on the rest is history history's top monkeys history's greatest eunuchs historical love island disco may well have people who thought monkeys was perfectly reasonable raising their eyebrows and saying is this history but i think it is history i think it's a really interesting cultural moment i think it's a nice way actually to look at america in the 1970s so we did an episode about New York, didn't we?
汤姆，它正准备在美国全国范围内爆发。然后，当然，走向世界，走向全球。在我们做过的所有《历史的余味》主题中，比如“历史上的顶级猴子”、“历史上最伟大的太监”、“历史上的恋爱岛”，迪斯科可能会让那些觉得“猴子”那一期非常合理的人挑起眉毛，问这算历史吗？但我认为这就是历史。我认为这是一个非常有趣的文化时刻，我认为这实际上是审视20世纪70年代美国的一个很好的切入点。我们做过一期关于纽约的节目，不是吗？
The urban crisis in New York a year ago. And I think a lot of this is also in New York, but it's a very different way of exploring that story. Well, I mean, it is a story that's palpably set against crisis. Yeah. So the Bee Gees and so Saturday Night Fever is actually incredibly gritty. Yes. I mean, it's a kind of faintly dystopian quality. But the Saturday Night Fever is because that's where you lose it.
一年前关于纽约城市危机的节目。我认为其中很多内容也发生在纽约，但这是一种探索那个故事的非常不同的方式。嗯，我的意思是，这是一个明显以危机为背景的故事。是的。所以比吉斯乐队（Bee Gees）和《周末夜狂热》（Saturday Night Fever）实际上是非常写实的。是的。我的意思是，它有一种淡淡的反乌托邦色彩。但《周末夜狂热》之所以存在，是因为那是你释放自我的地方。
You go and lose yourself in the dancing. Yeah, it's escapism. And that's the whole point, isn't it? It is, absolutely. It's a kind of hedonistic escape. It is. There are themes, though, running through the sort of what you might call the wider conversation about escape that would be very familiar to people listening to this podcast right now. 21st century themes. So there's a tension between the heartland and the coasts in the United States. There are lots of people who despise disco. There's a racial dimension. There's also a kind of sexual dimension. So disco becomes identified very much with kind of gay rights, gay liberation and so on.
你去那里，在舞蹈中迷失自我。是的，这是一种逃避现实。这就是重点，不是吗？绝对是。这是一种享乐主义的逃避。确实如此。不过，贯穿于你所说的关于“逃避”的更广泛讨论中的主题，对于现在收听这个播客的人来说会非常熟悉。这是21世纪的主题。所以，美国腹地与沿海地区之间存在着张力。有很多人鄙视迪斯科。这其中有种族因素。还有一种性方面的因素。所以迪斯科变得与同性恋权利、同性恋解放运动等紧密联系在一起。
And then the backlash against disco is driven by people who are often overtly homophobic. So I think there's a lot going on, actually, in the disco story. Yeah, brilliant. I'm completely convinced. Okay, very good. And you are a top historian of America. Oh, Tom, that's kind. And I always profit from what you tell me.
然后，对迪斯科的抵制是由那些通常公开恐同的人推动的。所以我认为，实际上迪斯科的故事里有很多内容。太棒了。我完全被说服了。好的，非常好。而且你是美国顶尖的历史学家。哦，汤姆，你太客气了。我总是从你告诉我的事情中获益。
This is so kind. Thank you. So looking forward to it. Good. So would you like me to tell you where Disco was born? I would. Brilliant. So Disco is born in a particular part of Manhattan in the Soho district, south of Houston Street,
你太客气了。谢谢。非常期待。好的。那么你想让我告诉你迪斯科是在哪里诞生的吗？我想知道。太棒了。所以迪斯科诞生于曼哈顿的一个特定区域，即休斯顿街以南的苏豪区。
which was then nicknamed Hell's Hundred Acres, people called it. So this is at the turn of the 1970s. So it's at a point when that particular part of Manhattan, for those of you who are familiar with it, is not yet kind of gentrified. You don't find Robert De Niro opening Italian restaurants or art galleries there. It is very kind of grimy and dingy and run down.
当时人们称之为“地狱百英亩”（Hell's Hundred Acres）。所以这是在20世纪70年代之交。对于那些熟悉曼哈顿的人来说，那个特定区域当时还没有被绅士化。你找不到罗伯特·德尼罗（Robert De Niro）在那里开意大利餐厅或艺术画廊。那里非常肮脏、破旧且衰败。
All the things that we talked about in our fear city episode last year and um discotheques generally so vince alessi in that article in rolling stone that you read out for 1973 he talks about discotheque rock i'm obviously we think of disco and rock as being kind of polar opposites now don't we but the idea of the discotheque is a european idea so obviously it shares a route with kind of bibliotheque. So it's French. It's French. Supposedly.
所有我们在去年“恐惧之城”（Fear City）那一期中谈到的事情，以及迪斯科舞厅通常的情况……所以文斯·阿拉西在你读的那篇1973年的《滚石》文章中，他谈到了“迪斯科摇滚”。显然，我们现在认为迪斯科和摇滚是截然相反的，不是吗？但迪斯科舞厅的概念是一个欧洲概念。所以很明显，它与“图书馆”（bibliotheque）有着共同的词根。所以它是法语。它是法语。大概吧。
I mean, it's one of these things that you can't really verify. The first discotheque was in Paris in 1947. There's a club called the Whiskey A Go-Go that claims to be the first one. But I bet they're all wearing jackets. Yeah. And kind of swinging their arms in a suave, but it would be fair to say not energetic manner. I would imagine one hand definitely holding a cigarette. I mean, it's Paris in the 1940s.
我的意思是，这是那种你无法真正核实的事情之一。第一家迪斯科舞厅是1947年在巴黎出现的。有一家叫“威士忌去去”（Whiskey A Go-Go）的俱乐部声称是第一家。但我敢打赌他们都穿着西装外套。是的，以一种文雅但可以肯定地说并不激进的方式挥动着手臂。我想象其中一只手肯定拿着一支烟。我的意思是，那是20世纪40年代的巴黎。
The other gesticulating to Jean-Paul Sartre as you dance. So anyway, that claims to be the first discotheque to play recorded music, not to have a live band. Because of course, why would you have, you know, record players are expensive. Records are relatively expensive. It would be cheaper and easier to have live music. But in Europe in the 1950s and 1960s, it becomes increasingly common to have somebody just playing records rather than having a live band.
另一只手在跳舞时向让-保罗·萨特（Jean-Paul Sartre）挥舞。总之，那家店声称是第一家播放录制音乐而不是现场乐队的迪斯科舞厅。因为当然，你为什么要……你知道，唱片机很贵。唱片相对昂贵。拥有现场音乐会更便宜、更容易。但在20世纪50年代和60年代的欧洲，找人播放唱片而不是请现场乐队变得越来越普遍。
But it's not popular in the United States at all, so it's very rare throughout the 60s. So it's kind of seen as cheating? I think it is cheating, yeah. I think it would be seen as cheating. It would just be seen as a bit rubbish. Why would you go to hear somebody play music, recorded music, when you can hear a band?
但这在美国一点也不流行，所以整个60年代都非常罕见。所以这被视为作弊？我认为这确实是作弊，是的。我认为这会被视为作弊。这只会被看作有点垃圾。当你能听到现场乐队时，为什么要花钱去听别人播放录制好的音乐呢？
Yeah. But, so in these sort of quite sleazy streets of Hell's Kitchen and Soho, disco is born. And there are a whole load of clubs in the end of the 1960s. So all the radical excitement and the idealism of the 1960s is kind of curdled.
是的。但是，在“地狱厨房”和苏豪区那些相当肮脏的街道上，迪斯科诞生了。在20世纪60年代末，那里有一大堆俱乐部。所以60年代所有的激进兴奋和理想主义都变质了。
And the most famous of these clubs is a club called The Sanctuary. So this is in Hell's Kitchen. It's between 9th and 10th Avenue in Manhattan. Tom, it is in a disused Baptist church. Could the symbolism be more exciting? Yeah. Ecstasy.
这些俱乐部中最著名的是一家叫“圣所”（The Sanctuary）的俱乐部。它位于地狱厨房。在曼哈顿的第9大道和第10大道之间。汤姆，它位于一座废弃的浸信会教堂里。象征意义还能更令人兴奋吗？是的。狂喜。
Yeah. They play Motown. They play kind of psychedelic rock. They play sort of drumming and stuff. And this club is the Sanctuary. This clean cell is largely gay. You can see it, actually. Have you ever seen the film Clute?
是的。他们播放摩城音乐（Motown）。他们播放迷幻摇滚。他们播放那种鼓点之类的东西。这家俱乐部就是“圣所”。这个群体主要是同性恋。你其实可以看出来。你看过电影《柳巷芳草》（Klute）吗？
No. From 1971. So it's a Donald Sutherland, Jane Fonda film. It's an Alan Jay Peculia film. It's one of these very sort of paranoid, gritty thrillers that Hollywood was producing at the beginning of the 1970s. It's like the Parallax View or the French Connection or Serpico. You know, that sort of everything's covered in graffiti,
没有。那是1971年的电影。那是唐纳德·萨瑟兰（Donald Sutherland）和简·方达（Jane Fonda）主演的电影。那是艾伦·J·帕库拉（Alan J. Pakula）的电影。这是好莱坞在70年代初制作的那种非常偏执、写实的惊悚片之一。就像《视差》（The Parallax View）、《法国贩毒网》（The French Connection）或《冲突》（Serpico）。你知道，那种到处都是涂鸦、
hard-bitten corrupt cops, all of that kind of thing. But flares. Lots of flares. And Jane Fonda goes to this club, and the club is The Sanctuary. And they had a disc jockey called Francis Grasso, who was from Brooklyn. He was born in the late 40s.
顽固腐败的警察，所有这些东西。但是有喇叭裤。很多喇叭裤。简·方达去了这家俱乐部，这家俱乐部就是“圣所”。他们有一位名叫弗朗西斯·格拉索（Francis Grasso）的唱片骑师，他来自布鲁克林。他出生于40年代末。
And he's basically, I think, the first DJ that people had heard of. People in the know, anyway. It's not a household name by any means, but people in the know would have heard of. So is he the godfather of disco? The thing is, disco actually has two fathers. So he's one of the fathers. Yeah, that's very 1970s, Stonewall.
基本上，我认为他是人们听说过的第一位DJ。无论如何，圈内人是知道的。这绝不是家喻户晓的名字，但圈内人会听说过。所以他是迪斯科的教父吗？问题是，迪斯科实际上有两个父亲。所以他是其中一位父亲。是的，这非常70年代，石墙事件。
Very 70s. So first of all, what he does is he is unusual among DJs. He ignores the charts and just plays his own thing so is that not a thing up until then because that for me is the definition of cool is that you're ignoring the charts oh no I think people generally just follow the charts so there isn't a kind of underground where it's all the kind of hippest people yeah the whole point is that you are listening to stuff that no one else listens to. Well, you are hearing bands.
非常70年代。首先，他与众不同的地方在于，他无视排行榜，只播放自己的东西。所以在那之前这不是一种常态吗？因为对我来说，酷的定义就是无视排行榜。哦，不，我认为人们通常只是追随排行榜，所以不存在那种全是时髦人士的地下圈子。是的，重点是你正在听别人没听过的东西。嗯，你听到的是乐队。
I mean, that's the thing, right? I mean, let's imagine you're in Britain. So you're in London, 1967, and you want to go to a bar and there'll be music. It will probably be a live band. And you're taking complete potluck. It could be something quite pioneering, or it could be something that's just a knockoff Rolling Stones impersonators. Right. But to go back to Liverpool in the late 50s, the Beatles are picking up stuff from sailors who are bringing weird records that nobody else
我的意思是，就是这样，对吧？我的意思是，让我们想象你在英国。你在1967年的伦敦，你想去一家酒吧，那里会有音乐。那可能是一个现场乐队。你完全是在碰运气。它可能是某种相当开创性的东西，也可能只是模仿滚石乐队的冒牌货。没错。但回到50年代末的利物浦，披头士乐队（The Beatles）从水手那里收集东西，水手们带来了没人听过的奇怪唱片。
has heard of. Of course they are. Yeah. So there's something of that in New York now, isn't there? That they're bringing in kind of African music and European music and they're kind of mixing it up. They are, absolutely. Rather in the way that rock and roll groups in Liverpool in the late 50s were doing it with American music. Yeah. I mean, the obscurity was a marker of cool. Absolutely.
当然是这样。是的。所以现在纽约也有类似的情况，不是吗？他们带来了非洲音乐和欧洲音乐，然后把它们混合在一起。他们确实如此，绝对是。就像50年代末利物浦的摇滚乐队用美国音乐做的那样。是的。我的意思是，冷门是酷的标志。绝对是。
And obscurity is always a marker of cool. But by and large, I mean, don't forget, there aren't many DJs. Of course. I mean, that's an amazing thing to think of. Yeah, of course. And what DJs there are generally follow the charts. And certainly a radio DJ is going to follow the charts because a radio DJ in a commercially funded radio station
冷门永远是酷的标志。但总的来说，我的意思是，别忘了，DJ并不多。当然。我的意思是，这是一个令人惊奇的想法。是的，当然。现有的DJ通常都追随排行榜。当然，电台DJ肯定会追随排行榜，因为商业电台的电台DJ
is dependent on high listening figures. And they are going to prosper if they're playing, you know, in 1964, they're playing Manfred Mann and the Dave Clark Five. And in 1968, they're playing The Doors. Yeah, okay. Yeah, they're following the trends and so the obscurity of the spaces in which discos are being held yeah all these kind of club nights i mean it's not being called discos at this point yeah that is what enables people to mess around
依赖于高收听率。如果他们在1964年播放曼弗雷德·曼（Manfred Mann）和戴夫·克拉克五人组（The Dave Clark Five），在1968年播放大门乐队（The Doors），他们就会成功。是的，好吧。是的，他们追随潮流，所以迪斯科举办空间的冷门性，是的，所有这些俱乐部之夜，我的意思是，当时并没有被称为迪斯科，是的，这正是让人们能够摆弄
with their african records and so on exactly this is a very niche thing it's in this place the sanctuary which most people have never heard of so francis grasso he plays obscure music and secondly he has the idea of having basically a set that is a unified coherent of as it were and does that involve kind of merging the tracks into one another so that there's never a moment of point of silence it It is indeed. So beat mixing, I believe, Tom, is the technical term. And he's also the first DJ supposedly to do slip queuing. I'm so glad you're here to explain all this. Well, you know, I'm very much into my DJ terminology.
他们的非洲唱片等等的原因。没错，这是一个非常小众的事情。它在这个大多数人从未听说过的“圣所”里。所以弗朗西斯·格拉索，他播放冷门的音乐，其次，他有了基本上把一套音乐变成一个统一、连贯的整体的想法。这是否涉及将曲目融合在一起，以至于没有沉默的时刻？确实如此。所以“节拍混音”（beat mixing），我相信，汤姆，是专业术语。而且他据说是第一个做“滑入式排队”（slip queuing）的DJ。我很高兴你在这里解释这一切。嗯，你知道，我非常热衷于DJ术语。
Yeah. So slip queuing is basically... The chipping Norton sound. He has a record in place above the turntable, and he will make sure that it kicks in at exactly the right moment so the beat queuing is so that the kind of the beat will overlap so that synchronize the beat of the two different records so one will meld seamlessly into another and the slip queuing is that there is no moment of silence that it just goes from one anyway that's what it is yeah
是的。所以“滑入式排队”基本上是……奇平诺顿（Chipping Norton）的声音。他在转盘上方放了一张唱片，他会确保它在最准确的时刻切入，所以“节拍排队”是为了让节拍重叠，从而同步两张不同唱片的节拍，这样一张唱片就能无缝地融入另一张唱片，而“滑入式排队”意味着没有沉默的时刻，它只是从一个过渡到另一个。总之，就是这样。
brilliant it's like you talking about ships. Brilliant. Thank you. So anyway, if you go to the sanctuary in 1970, it's not like going to other clubs. It's a much more all enveloping, immersive experience. There's a ton of drugs. So drugs run right through this story. And the drug of choice is cocaine? Not at this point, I would say. Cocaine comes in a bit later. We were talking a lot about cocaine a bit later. So the sanctuaries, as I understand it, I mean, obviously I'm too young to have gone to the sanctuary, Tom. And to be frank with you, I don't want to disappoint you or the listeners. I don't feel it really would have been my scene. Okay. It is awash with poppers, amyl nitrate, and with quaaludes.
太棒了，就像你在谈论船只一样。太棒了。谢谢。总之，如果你在1970年去“圣所”，那和去其他俱乐部不一样。这是一种更全面、更沉浸式的体验。那里有大量的毒品。所以毒品贯穿了这个故事。首选毒品是可卡因吗？我不认为在那个阶段是。可卡因是后来才出现的。我们稍后会谈论很多关于可卡因的事情。据我所知，“圣所”——我的意思是，显然我太年轻了，没去过“圣所”，汤姆。坦白说，我不想让你或听众失望。我觉得那真的不会是我的菜。好吧。那里充斥着波普尔（poppers，亚硝酸异戊酯）和安眠酮（Quaaludes）。
Quaaludes are a massive thing in America in the 70s. I don't know what they are. So they're basically relaxants, you know, sedatives. And relaxants for, so is there sex going on? There is undoubtedly sex going on. There is a lot of sex in this podcast. And it's gay sex, presumably. So the drugs and the sex are...
安眠酮在70年代的美国非常盛行。我不知道那是什么。所以它们基本上是松弛剂，你知道，镇静剂。松弛剂是为了……所以那里有性行为吗？毫无疑问有性行为。这个播客里有很多关于性的内容。而且大概是同性恋性行为。所以毒品和性是……
Part of the same. I mean, this is sex, drugs and rock and roll, except the rock and roll is not rock and roll as we would classically understand it fine okay so that's happening at the sanctuary and i said there were two fathers there's another place where this is happening and this is a place called the loft so there's a guy called david mancuso he's a civil rights activist he's an anti-vietnam war activist so we're in again we're in 1970 and this is the point when if you're in the civil rights movement or the anti-vietnam war movement the great utopian hopes that you had three years earlier have really turned sour. You know, Nixon is president.
同一件事的一部分。我的意思是，这就是性、毒品和摇滚乐，只不过摇滚乐不是我们传统理解的那种摇滚乐。好吧，没问题。所以这发生在“圣所”。我说过有两个父亲，还有另一个地方也在发生这种情况，这个地方叫“阁楼”（The Loft）。有一个叫大卫·曼库索（David Mancuso）的人，他是一位民权活动家，也是一位反越战活动家。所以我们又回到了1970年，这是当你身处民权运动或反越战运动时，你三年前怀有的伟大乌托邦希望已经真正变质的时刻。你知道，尼克松是总统。
There are still big demonstrations going on, but certainly the civil rights aspect, it's really become very fragmented and polarised, and the tone of life is so different. But Dominic, can I ask you, one of the things that happens in the 60s and then in the 70s is that gay rights, it kind of takes up the model of civil rights movement as it had been in the 50s and 60s. Yeah. Is that something that is starting to kick in at this point? So the Stonewall Riots are when? 1969.
仍然有大规模的示威活动，但民权方面确实变得非常碎片化和两极分化，生活的基调也大不相同。但是多米尼克，我可以问你吗，60年代和70年代发生的事情之一是，同性恋权利运动采用了50年代和60年代民权运动的模式。是的。这是在此时开始发挥作用的东西吗？那么石墙骚乱是什么时候？1969年。
Yeah. So yes, but the Stonewall Riots, we'll probably talk about this a little bit later when we talk a bit more about the gay subculture of New York and San Francisco. The Stonewall stuff, I think, looms larger in retrospect than it did at the time. Right. Okay. Because I think if you're in Wichita, Kansas, do you think of 1969 as the year of the Stonewall riots?
是的。所以是的，但石墙骚乱，我们稍后谈论纽约和旧金山的同性恋亚文化时可能会再谈。我认为石墙事件在回顾中比在当时显得更重要。没错。好吧。因为如果你在堪萨斯州的威奇托，你会把1969年看作是石墙骚乱的一年吗？
You absolutely don't. No. But if you're in manhattan you do if you're in manhattan and you're gay and you're part of that scene then yes absolutely you do if you're in manhattan and you're oblivious to all that i mean i don't think it looms terribly large in your consciousness compared with vietnam or compared with the nixon presidency or whatever anyway david mancuso he is gay and on valentine's day in 1970 he invites all of his friends and their friends and acquaintances and stuff he says he's going to throw a big party in this loft space at 647 broadway he actually thinks everything has kind of fallen apart and it's very gloomy now the radical dream of the 60s has dissipated and he wants to cheer people up.
你绝对不会。不。但如果你在曼哈顿，你会的。如果你在曼哈顿，你是同性恋，并且你是那个圈子的一部分，那么是的，绝对会。如果你在曼哈顿，对这一切一无所知，我的意思是，我不认为它在你的意识中比越南战争、尼克松总统或其他什么事情更重要。总之，大卫·曼库索是同性恋，1970年情人节，他邀请了他所有的朋友、朋友的朋友和熟人等等。他说他要在百老汇647号的这个阁楼空间举办一场大型派对。他实际上认为一切都已经分崩离析，现在非常阴郁。60年代的激进梦想已经消散，他想让人们振作起来。
And the party, the slogan is love saves the day. And it's an attempt, I suppose, to preserve the spirit of the 60s, to resuscitate it. So he has this party. There's black and white there. His sound engineer, the guy who did the sound for him, said it was about 60% black and 70% gay. There was a mix of sexual orientation a mix of races a mix of economic groups it was a real mix and the common
派对的口号是“爱拯救这一天”（Love Saves the Day）。我想，这是一种试图保留60年代精神、使其复苏的尝试。所以他举办了这场派对。那里有黑人和白人。他的音响工程师，那个为他做音响的人，说大约60%是黑人，70%是同性恋。有各种性取向的混合，各种种族的混合，各种经济群体的混合，这真的是一种混合，而共同点
denominator was music and so mancuso does the music himself and rather like francis grasso at the sanctuary he says listen instead of having a song then a break then another song let's weave it all together into this kind of wall of sound. And he has very eclectic tastes. And people love it. And he says, well, let's make this a regular thing. So he has effectively what you use the phrase club nights. He has a kind of weekly party.
是音乐。所以曼库索自己负责音乐，就像“圣所”的弗朗西斯·格拉索一样，他说，听着，与其放一首歌，然后休息，再放另一首歌，不如把它们编织在一起，形成这种“音墙”。而且他的品味非常折衷。人们很喜欢它。他说，好吧，让我们把它变成常态。所以他实际上拥有了你所说的“俱乐部之夜”。他有一种每周一次的派对。
He says, let's make the loft a regular thing. So it basically becomes this members-only disco club that happens every week. And he chooses the music. and he has two turntables and he puts it all together. And sort of the word spreads that there's this guy and he's doing really, really eclectic stuff. If you love music, go to these parties. They're really cool parties, lots of drugs, lots of sex, all of this kind of business. And what about the music? Is it kind of evolving towards what we would recognize as disco by this point? Yes, it is.
他说，让我们把“阁楼”变成常态。所以它基本上变成了每周一次的会员制迪斯科俱乐部。他选择音乐。他有两个转盘，把一切组合在一起。消息传开了，说有这么一个人，他在做非常、非常折衷的东西。如果你热爱音乐，就去参加这些派对。它们是非常酷的派对，有很多毒品，有很多性，所有这些生意。那音乐呢？到这个时候，它是否正在演变成我们所认知的迪斯科？是的，它是。
It is. Absolutely, it is. So the song that people always point to as the foundation stone of disco is actually Cameroonian. It's by a Cameroonian saxophonist called Mano de Bango, called Sol Macosa. Lots of people who are interested in music will have heard of that and you can you know look it up on youtube or whatever i think this is the first time we've mentioned cameroon yeah since cannibal cannibal yeah peter the great cameroonian general yeah yeah it's great to get cameroon back on the podcast yeah it is great to have him back so um this was released
它是。绝对是。所以人们总是指出作为迪斯科基石的歌曲实际上是喀麦隆的。它是由一位喀麦隆萨克斯风手马努·迪班戈（Manu Dibango）创作的，叫《Soul Makossa》。很多对音乐感兴趣的人都会听说过，你可以在YouTube上查一下。我想这是我们第一次提到喀麦隆，是的，自从“食人族”那一期之后，彼得大帝的喀麦隆将军，是的，很高兴能让喀麦隆回到播客中，是的，很高兴他回来了。所以，这首歌发行于
in 1972 and obviously nobody in amer America cared about it at all. And actually, what had happened is it was a B-side from a song called The Hymn of the Eighth African Cup of Nations. Wonderful. So it was celebrating the fact that Cameroon had got to the quarterfinals of the African Cup of Nations football tournament. And Cameroon was hosting the games as well. And this was the B-side done by this Cameroonian saxophonist he got a Cameroonian poet to write the lyrics in Douala a native Cameroonian language anyway Mancuso basically somehow got hold of this record and he played it and people loved it they thought it was brilliant and actually he played it so much
1972年，显然美国没人关心它。实际上，发生的事情是，它是《第八届非洲国家杯赞歌》这首歌的B面。太棒了。所以它是在庆祝喀麦隆进入了非洲国家杯足球锦标赛的四分之一决赛。喀麦隆也是比赛的主办国。这是由这位喀麦隆萨克斯风手制作的B面，他找了一位喀麦隆诗人用杜阿拉语（一种喀麦隆本土语言）写了歌词。总之，曼库索不知怎么弄到了这张唱片，他播放了它，人们很喜欢，他们认为这太棒了，实际上他播放得太多了，
that local DJs in New York picked up on it and they started was brilliant and actually he played it so much that local djs in new york picked up on it and they started playing it and atlantic records then heard about it and they released it in the united states and it got to i think the top 30 or the top 20 or something like that the billboard chart so it's the first proto disco song to become a sort of commercial phenomenon now you may be thinking well what is the difference between a disco song? Because Vince Alessi, in his column in 1973, he talked about discotheque rock. Like he wasn't drawing a distinction between disco music and rock music. But certainly by 1973, people are conscious that there's a kind of music that is slightly different.
以至于纽约当地的DJ们注意到了它，他们开始播放它，大西洋唱片公司（Atlantic Records）听说了这件事，他们在美国发行了它，它进入了公告牌排行榜的前30名或前20名左右。所以这是第一首成为商业现象的原始迪斯科歌曲。现在你可能在想，迪斯科歌曲和摇滚歌曲有什么区别？因为文斯·阿拉西在1973年的专栏中谈到了“迪斯科摇滚”。好像他并没有在迪斯科音乐和摇滚音乐之间划清界限。但到1973年，人们肯定意识到有一种音乐是略有不同的。
And although we are, of course, not, the rest is musicology. Tom, I think it would be fun to do some musicological analysis, don't you? Yeah, it would. We love musicological analysis. Brilliant. On The Rest is History. Do we not, Dominic? We do.
虽然我们当然不是，但《历史的余味》是音乐学。汤姆，我认为做一些音乐学分析会很有趣，不是吗？是的，会很有趣。我们热爱音乐学分析。太棒了。在《历史的余味》里。我们不是吗，多米尼克？我们是。
So obviously the influences on disco, Motown is an obvious one. Soul music is an obvious one too. What is the disco sound? So first of all, the rhythm is syncopated. And what that means is that the rhythm often feels like it's being kind of interrupted, like it's kind of offbeat. So it's got a kind of restlessness to it. It doesn't kind of lull you into sort of somnolence or passivity
所以很明显，迪斯科的影响，摩城音乐是一个明显的例子。灵魂乐也是一个明显的例子。什么是迪斯科之声？首先，节奏是切分的。这意味着节奏通常感觉像是被打断了，就像它是“反拍”的。所以它有一种不安感。它不会让你陷入昏昏欲睡或被动状态，
because they're interrupting the rhythm. You don't really know where it's going okay there's a bass drum you know i know a lot of this is kind of musical jargon but everyone will know what i mean when i say the bass drum is giving you what people call a four on the floor beat and all that is is like that kind of beat which is absolutely there in almost all disco singles and is not there in you you know, a Beatles record or a Rolling Stones record or whatever it might be. That's probably the single thing that marks that disco from rock music. Yeah. The vocals, the vocals are often, lots of people always call them sort of soaring vocals.
因为它打断了节奏。你真的不知道它要去哪里。好吧，有一个低音鼓，我知道这其中很多是音乐术语，但当我说低音鼓给你提供人们所说的“四拍到底”（four on the floor）节奏时，每个人都会明白我的意思。这就是那种节奏，它几乎存在于所有的迪斯科单曲中，而在披头士或滚石乐队的唱片中则不存在。这可能是将迪斯科与摇滚音乐区分开来的单一标志。是的。人声，人声通常是，很多人总是称它们为“高亢的人声”。
They kind of reverberate. Or maybe even orgasmic. Orgasmic, right. So let's think about... Donna Summer. Donna Summer, a classic kind of discoberate. Or maybe even orgasmic. Orgasmic, right. So let's think about... Donna Summer. Donna Summer, a classic kind of disco sound I feel love. If you think of Donna Summer's voice in that, or Gloria Gaynor's voice in I Will Survive,
它们会产生回响。或者甚至是“高潮般的”。高潮般的，没错。让我们想想……唐娜·萨默（Donna Summer）。唐娜·萨默，一种经典的迪斯科之声，《I Feel Love》。如果你想到唐娜·萨默在那首歌里的声音，或者格洛丽亚·盖纳（Gloria Gaynor）在《I Will Survive》里的声音，
or any of these things, they're kind of soaring, anthemic vocals that often have this kind of echo to them. So they've obviously been very highly produced. And the sound generally, it's big and it feels kind of artificial. It's not five blokes in a cellar. No. It's strings and an orchestra and horns.
或者任何这些东西，它们都是那种高亢的、赞歌式的人声，通常带有回声。所以它们显然经过了非常精心的制作。而且整体声音很大，感觉有点人工。这不是五个家伙在地下室里演奏。不。这是弦乐、管弦乐队和号角。
But Dominic, do you know what Donna Summer said about Love to Love You Baby? Come on, Tom, tell me. Oh, yeah, that one. Thank you. You just made this point purely so you could make that noise. Well, no, Donna Summer said it wasn't her singing, but Marilyn Monroe. Really? Mm.
但是多米尼克，你知道唐娜·萨默关于《Love to Love You Baby》说了什么吗？来吧，汤姆，告诉我。哦，是的，那一首。谢谢。你刚才提出这一点纯粹是为了能发出那种声音。嗯，不，唐娜·萨默说那不是她在唱歌，而是玛丽莲·梦露。真的吗？嗯。
A friend of the rest is history. Yeah, very much a friend of the rest is history. So she is play acting Marilyn when she sang that. Is that so? Yeah. So there's a sort of great wall of sound. Phil Spector, of course, was the producer who was famous for his kind of wall of sound style. And this is even bigger in a way
《历史的余味》的朋友。是的，非常是《历史的余味》的朋友。所以她在唱那首歌时是在扮演玛丽莲。是这样吗？是的。所以有一种伟大的“音墙”。菲尔·斯佩克特（Phil Spector）当然是那位以“音墙”风格闻名的制作人。而这在某种程度上甚至更大。
so it's very expensive to make a disco record it's much more expensive than to make a stripped down you know rock and roll record from the 60s or indeed a punk single from later 70s yeah so the punk would be the contrast wouldn't it because you need an orchestra if you need an orchestra you need a conductor you need loads of mixing engineers i mean a disco single could conceivably start with 60 different tracks to be mixed together so the role of the producer is really really important and the most famous producer lots of people have heard of him georgio maroda so you mentioned donna summer he's donna summer's producer i feel love love to love you baby and so on and he is such a weird and interesting man so tell me he is from the south tyrol in italy so previously contested
所以制作一张迪斯科唱片非常昂贵，它比制作一张60年代那种精简的摇滚唱片，或者70年代后期的朋克单曲要昂贵得多。是的，所以朋克会是对比，不是吗？因为你需要一个管弦乐队，如果你需要一个管弦乐队，你需要一个指挥，你需要大量的混音工程师。我的意思是，一张迪斯科单曲可能从60个不同的音轨混合在一起开始。所以制作人的角色非常、非常重要。最著名的制作人，很多人都听说过他，乔治·莫罗德（Giorgio Moroder）。所以你提到了唐娜·萨默，他是唐娜·萨默的制作人，《I Feel Love》、《Love to Love You Baby》等等。他是一个如此古怪而有趣的人。所以告诉我，他来自意大利的南蒂罗尔，之前在意大利和奥地利之间有争议，他是拉登人（Ladin）。我的意思是，他不是像阿拉丁那样带着神灯，他是拉登人。是的，所以拉登人是一种讲拉丁语形式的罗曼语族人。是的。所以他是蒂罗尔的一个少数群体。他是酒店礼宾部的儿子。他自学音乐。他搬到了慕尼黑。
between italy and austria and he is aladdin i mean he's not aladdin like with his lamp he is a ladin yeah so the ladins are a kind of romance people who speak. Form of Latin. Yeah. So he's sort of this minority in the Tyrol. And he's the son of a hotel concierge. He teaches himself music. He moves to Munich.
当他在60年代末在慕尼黑时，他遇到了一个叫唐娜·盖恩斯（Donna Gaines）的女人。她是美国人。她去慕尼黑是为了出演《毛发》（Hair），那部放荡的音乐剧，时髦的音乐剧，我想。时髦，这是认可的术语吗？是的。她嫁给了一个叫赫尔穆特·萨默（Helmut Sommer）的奥地利人。我不知道这个人是什么样的。所以因此叫唐娜·萨默。
And when he's in Munich at the end of the 60s, he meets this woman who's called Donna Gaines. And she's American. She's gone to Munich to be in Hair, the licentious musical, groovy musical, I think. Groovy, is that the approved term? Yeah. And she marries an Austrian called Helmut Sommer. I have no knowledge of what this man is like. So hence Donna Sommer.
因此叫唐娜·萨默。她把它英语化为Sommer。赫尔穆特·萨默，我的意思是，他是一个传记还没被写出来的人。我想他是个演员。没错。我能想象他时不时穿着奥地利民族服装。好吧，我们对我们的故事有很多有益的奥地利回应——那只猴子。
Hence Donna Sommer. She anglicizes it to Sommer. Helmut Sommer, I mean, he's a man whose biography has not been written. I think he's an actor. Right. I imagine him dressing in Austrian national dress from time to time. Well, we had a lot of helpful Austrian responses to our story of the- The monkey.
红毛猩猩。是的。所以也许，如果还有任何奥地利听众，他们可以帮助我们，是的，我根本不想介绍赫尔穆特·萨默，但我能想象当他喝醉了，喝着奥地利葡萄酒时，他可能会发表一些不恰当的言论。我觉得这有点苛刻。你觉得太苛刻了吗？是的，我不知道，那只是纯粹的偏见，别管它，纯粹的偏见。总之，他们合作并制作了可能是所有迪斯科唱片中最著名的一首，《I Feel Love》。你认为那是名气最大的吗？
Yeah. The orangutan. Yeah. So perhaps, again, if there are any austrian listeners they could help us with this yeah i don't want to introduce helmut sommer at all but i imagine that when he was in his cups and kind of austrian wine he might express off-color opinions i think that's a little bit harsh you reckon that's too harsh yeah i don't know it's just pure prejudice speaking there just ignore it pure prejudice so anyway they collaborate and they produce probably the most famous of all disco records I feel love. Do you think that's the most famous?
我不知道。《I Will Survive》也许。是的。或者比吉斯乐队的那些。比吉斯乐队，但比吉斯乐队有点……我知道他们是仿制品。是的。但他们可能是最著名的。看，这里有一点张力，听众会注意到的。因为《Stayin' Alive》被用于心跳，不是吗？是的。让心脏恢复跳动。给人们做口对口人工呼吸。
I don't know. I Will Survive, maybe. Yeah. Or the Bee Gees ones. The Bee Gees, but the Bee Gees are sort of... I know they're ersatz. Yeah. But they probably are the most famous. See, there's a bit of attention which listeners will pick up on. Because the staying alive is used for heartbeats, isn't it? It is. Bringing hearts back. Doing mouth to mouth on people. Mouth to mouth resuscitation. Bringing hearts back. Doing mouth-to-mouth on people.
口对口人工呼吸。那是我刚才想找的词。是的。所以我认为那可能是。公平地说，这个播客里有很多口对口。不仅仅是口对口。没错。所以总之，回到迪斯科现象。
Mouth-to-mouth resuscitation. That's the phrase I was groping for. Yeah. So I would argue that that is possibly. To be fair, there's a hell of a lot of mouth-to-mouth in this podcast. And not just mouth-to-mouth. Right. So anyway, back to the disco phenomenon.
到1974年左右，迪斯科。那种音乐风格肯定已经从最初的那些俱乐部渗透出来了。所以有很多模仿者。那种“阁楼”场景变得非常时髦。有说法称，基本上有10万纽约人会去跳这种非常重低音的音乐。顺便说一句，这是一个技术术语，人们会盛装打扮。所以这是迪斯科场景的重要组成部分，不是吗，汤姆？你会穿上自以为是的颓废服装。你觉得这公平吗？你知道那种，是的，聚酯纤维，是的，彼得·弗兰科潘（Peter Frankopan）风格的衬衫，敞开到腰部。极其紧身。
Disco by about 1974. That style of music has definitely seeped out from beyond those original clubs. So there are many imitators of them. That kind of loft scene has become very fashionable. There are claims that basically 100,000 New Yorkers will go out dancing to this very kind of bass heavy kind of music.'s a technical term by the way and people will dress up so this is a big part of the disco scene isn't it tom that you will dress in self-consciously kind of decadent clothes do you think that's fair you know that sort of yeah polyester yeah sort of peter francopan style shirt open to the waist. Incredibly tight.
是的。彼得非常、非常迪斯科。极其紧身的裤子，由可怕的合成纤维制成的巨大喇叭裤，非常刺眼的颜色。但也有一种羽毛围巾。绝对是。所以我想在边缘也有点埃尔顿·约翰（Elton John）和华丽摇滚（glam rock）的暗示。绝对是。绝对是。迪斯科，我想，顺便说一句，我认为它在美国是一个比在英国大得多的现象。我的意思是，英国也有迪斯科，但它在与华丽摇滚和所有这些
Yeah. Peter's very, very disco. Incredibly tight trousers, massive flares made of horrendous synthetic fabrics, very lurid colors. But also kind of feather boas. Absolutely. So a faint hint of Elton John and glam rock, I guess, as well on the margins. Definitely. Definitely. Disco, I think, by the way, I think it is a much bigger phenomenon in was absolutely so a faint hint of elton john and glam rock i guess as well on the margins definitely definitely disco i think by the way i think it is a much bigger phenomenon in the u.s than it is in britain i mean there is disco in britain but it's jostling for attention with glam rock and all this
其他东西争夺注意力。所以实际上，我认为迪斯科在美国起飞的时候，在英国，很多都是“Slade”和“Wizzard”之类的。就像来自西米德兰兹郡的男人戴着闪亮的帽子。是的，他们不是同性恋权利的先驱。是的。好吧，我不知道。我的意思是，我不想预判Slade对性多样性的态度。我的意思是，迪斯科的特点是它公开且自豪。是的。而且是关于同性恋的。
other stuff so actually i think disco in the u.s is taking off at the point in britain where a lot of it is kind of slayed and wizard it's like men from the West Midlands with sort of shiny hats. Yeah, who were not pioneers of gay rights. Yeah. Well, I don't know. I mean, I don't want to prejudge Slade's attitude towards sexual diversity. I mean, the thing about disco is that it is out and proud. Yeah. And about being gay.
是的。以一种音乐之前可能没有过的方式。我认为这是真的。我认为它更加公开地是同性恋，我们稍后会谈到这一点。杜鲁门·卡波特（Truman Capote）在1974年的《今夜秀》（The Tonight Show）上，他有他选择的俱乐部，Le Jardin。他说，他描述在舞池里，这种可怕的搅动，整个地方像黄油搅拌机一样搅动。而Le Jardin，我的意思是，那种标语是它将成为“一个完全的同性恋体验”。所以他公开谈论这一点，以及他们把自己标榜为那样的事实，告诉你事情已经改变了多少。
Yes. In a way that presumably music hadn't been before. I think that's true. I think it is much more overtly gay what will come to this. Truman Capote on The Tonight Show in 1974, he has this club of choice, Le Jardin. And he says, he describes on the dance floor, this terrible churning, the whole place churning like a buttermilk machine. And Le Jardin, I mean, the sort of tagline was it was going to be quote a total gay experience so the fact that he's talking about that openly and the fact that they're billing themselves as that tells you how much things have have changed
好吧，为了准备这个，我读了鲍勃·斯坦利（Bob Stanley）在他精彩的流行音乐史中关于迪斯科的短文。是的，是的，是的，是的。在60年代之前，纽约的俱乐部禁止男人一起跳舞。在火岛（Fire Island）的俱乐部里，手电筒会照向舞者，以确保他们没有做任何像牵手这样颠覆性的事情。是的，所以从60年代的那种情况到十年后的迪斯科，我的意思是，这是一个巨大的变化，不是吗？哦，是的，这是一个彻底的巨变。但在我们进入同性恋之前，这非常重要，我认为迪斯科在那个时候成功的原因肯定是逃避现实。所以我们是在1974年。如果你考虑一下整体背景，经济状况远不如10年前。你经历了阿拉伯石油
well in preparation for this i read um bob stanley's short article on disco in his brilliant history of pop music yeah yeah yeah yeah men were forbidden from dancing together in new york until the 1960s at clubs on fire island flashlights were shone at dancers to make sure they weren't doing anything as subversive as even holding hands yes so to go from that in the 60s to disco a decade later i mean it's quite the sea change isn't it oh it is it's a total sea change but just before we get on to the um gay it, which is so important, I think there's definitely a case that disco, the reason for its success at that time is escapism. So we're in 1974. If you think about the context generally, the economy is nowhere near in the shape that it was 10 years earlier. You've had the Arab oil
冲击，欧佩克石油冲击。尼克松在70年代初试图制定收入政策。经济在1974、75年陷入衰退。越南，当然。我的意思是，他们撤出了越南。然后是水门事件。水门事件。这是一种非常、非常阴郁的情绪。而且它发生在纽约，一个真正处于困境的城市。《纽约每日新闻》在1975年采访了主席鲍勃·凯西（Bob Casey），全国迪斯科唱片骑师协会的主席。谁知道有这样一个机构？他说，当经济不景气时，人们总是会在跳舞中迷失自我。
shock, the OPEC oil shock. Nixon's tried to institute incomes policies at the beginning of the 1970s. The economy goes into a recession in 1974, 75. Vietnam, of course. I mean, they're out of Vietnam. And then Watergate. Watergate. It's a very, very gloomy mood. And it's in New York, which is in a city which is really on its uppers. The New York Daily News in 1975 interviewed the president, Bob Casey, president of the National Association of Discotheque Disc Jockeys. Who knew that there was such a body? And he said, people have always lost themselves in dancing when the economy has been bad.
迪斯科舞厅现在做的正是大萧条时期那些带有水晶吊灯的大舞厅所做的事情。每个人都出来花掉他们的失业救济金、福利金，来迷失自我。所以这显然是其中很大的一部分。是的。迷失在音乐中。迷失在音乐中。毒品显然是其中很大的一部分。所以毒品在70年代初比60年代或50年代更容易获得。部分原因是到这个时候，相当多的州已经开始放宽他们的毒品法律。所以我认为大约有11个州已经有效地将大麻的使用非刑事化。又有17个州减少了处罚。一个特别工作组在1975年告诉杰拉尔德·福特（Gerald Ford），我想，
Discos are now doing exactly the same thing that big dance halls with their crystal chandeliers did in the depression. Everyone is out to spend their unemployment check, their welfare, to lose themselves. So that's obviously a huge part of it. Yeah. Lost in music. Lost in music. The drugs is obviously a very big part of it. So drugs are much more available in the early 1970s than they were in the 60s or the 50s. And part of that is because by this point, quite a few states have already begun to relax their drugs laws. So I think something like 11 states have effectively decriminalized the use of marijuana. 17 more states have reduced the penalties. A task force tell Gerald Ford in, I think, 1975,
迪斯科舞厅现在所做的事情，与大萧条时期那些挂着水晶吊灯的大型舞厅如出一辙。每个人都拿出了失业救济金、福利金，只为沉浸其中，忘却自我。所以这显然是其中很大一部分原因。没错。沉浸在音乐中。沉浸在音乐中。毒品显然也是其中非常重要的一部分。20世纪70年代初，毒品的获取比60年代或50年代要容易得多。部分原因是到那时为止，相当多的州已经开始放宽毒品法律。我想大约有11个州实际上已经将大麻的使用非刑事化了。另有17个州减轻了处罚。一个特别工作组在1975年左右告诉杰拉尔德·福特，
you know, there's nothing that can be done. There's no point in a war on drugs because you'll never stamp it out. So there's an acceptance of drugs about 1974, 75, that there just wasn't 10 years earlier. And is this where cocaine is kicking in? So cocaine is definitely kicking in. You know, rock stars, they will go on TV and they will joke about taking cocaine. Now, if you think 10 years earlier, would the Beatles have done that in 1964, 65, 66? No way. When they first talk about taking LSD, it's very controversial. By the mid-70s, it is kind of taken for granted that rock stars are doing lots of drugs. And cocaine has come in
你知道，有些事情是无能为力的。禁毒战争毫无意义，因为你永远无法根除它。因此，到了1974、75年左右，人们对毒品的接受程度达到了十年前所没有的水平。这是可卡因开始流行的时候吗？是的，可卡因绝对是在那个时候开始流行的。你知道，摇滚明星会公开在电视上拿吸食可卡因开玩笑。现在，如果你回想十年前，披头士乐队会在1964、65、66年那样做吗？绝不可能。当他们第一次谈论服用LSD时，那是非常有争议的。到了70年代中期，摇滚明星大量吸毒被视为理所当然。而可卡因已经进入了
as the New York Times in 1974 calls it the champagne of drugs. There is this sort of sense in the 70s that cocaine is cost-free. There's a belief that it's the champagne of drugs there is this sort of sense in the 70s that cocaine is cost free there's a belief that it's not addictive that nobody suffers by you taking it people not really interested in where it comes from people are making jokes about uh you know at hollywood dinner parties everybody has the kind of gold spoon and the salver that is handed around with the white powder and all that kind of stuff and it is kind of guilt-free in the way that it wasn't previously and actually wouldn't be again is it like ecstasy influencing dance music in the 90s that cocaine becomes popular because of disco or is it disco is influenced by cocaine it's a good question i think both disco and cocaine are obviously trying
正如《纽约时报》在1974年所称，它是“毒品中的香槟”。70年代有一种感觉，认为可卡因是无害的。人们相信它是毒品中的香槟，70年代有一种感觉，认为可卡因是无害的，人们相信它不会上瘾，认为你吸食它不会伤害任何人，人们并不真正关心它从哪里来，人们在好莱坞的晚宴上开玩笑，每个人都有那种金勺子和盛着白色粉末的托盘，到处传递，所有这些东西，它在某种程度上是无罪恶感的，这在以前是不存在的，实际上以后也不会再有了。这就像90年代影响舞曲的摇头丸吗？可卡因是因为迪斯科而流行，还是迪斯科受到了可卡因的影响？这是一个好问题，我认为迪斯科和可卡因显然都在试图
to create a high aren't they they are ecstatic experiences yeah so i think they're probably feeding off one another is that the music is written and being produced to enhance the kind of the rush that cocaine gives and then people are taking cocaine because it fits with the style of the music i think it's fair to say they've got a relationship yeah okay now the other thing is, of course, the sexuality. So just to sort of widen the picture out a little bit, every state in the United States had anti-sodomy laws before the 1960s. The first state to repeal them was Illinois in 1962. Of course, there's no national law because that's not how America works. It's not like Britain, where Westminster legislates. That's not how it works in the United States, so it depends on your state. Illinois, first, 1962, and then there's a break until the 1970s. And then it's
创造一种快感，不是吗？它们都是令人狂喜的体验。是的，所以我认为它们可能是在相互促进，音乐的创作和制作是为了增强可卡因带来的那种冲动，然后人们吸食可卡因是因为它符合音乐的风格。我认为说它们之间有某种联系是公平的。是的，好了，另一件事当然是性取向。为了把视野放宽一点，在20世纪60年代之前，美国每个州都有反鸡奸法。第一个废除这些法律的州是1962年的伊利诺伊州。当然，没有全国性的法律，因为美国不是那样运作的。它不像英国，威斯敏斯特议会进行立法。美国不是那样运作的，所以这取决于你所在的州。伊利诺伊州是第一个，1962年，然后直到70年代才出现转机。然后是
the states that you would expect. It's Connecticut, Colorado, Oregon, more obviously liberal states that lead the way. And at at that point homosexuality is still seen well certainly in the 60s it was discussed as a disease so it's lost the kind of some of the moral charge the oppobrium from the victorian era let's say but people talk about it as a sort of terrible medical condition psychiatrist albert ell 1963, the exclusive homosexual is a psychopath. People are talking about therapy. Time magazine tells its readers in 1966, it's a misuse of the sexual faculty. Let's make no pretense that it's anything but a pernicious sickness, all of this sort of stuff. But obviously times are changing. You mentioned the Stonewall riots in 1969. I mean, I don't think they are quite as transformative as popular legend now believes.
你所预料的那些州。康涅狄格州、科罗拉多州、俄勒冈州，这些更明显的自由派州带头。在那时，同性恋仍然被视为——当然在60年代，它被讨论为一种疾病，所以它失去了一些维多利亚时代的道德指责和耻辱感，但人们把它当作一种可怕的医疗状况来谈论。精神病学家阿尔伯特·埃利斯在1963年说，纯粹的同性恋者是精神病患者。人们在谈论治疗。1966年，《时代》杂志告诉读者，这是对性功能的滥用。让我们不要假装它不是一种有害的疾病，诸如此类。但显然时代在变。你提到了1969年的石墙骚乱。我的意思是，我不认为它们像现在流行传说中认为的那样具有变革性。
Right. But maybe they become significant because people need a kind of dramatic starting point for something that is really starting to kick in by the mid-70s. Exactly. Exactly. So I think there is a definite sense that the plates are shifting in the early 1970s the first really big american reality show an american family where cameras tracked one particular family the son of the family who was called lance came out in the course of the show this is 1973 and now had he done that 10 years earlier, that would have been curtains for him. He'd have been finished. And actually, at the time, the New York Times reviewer laid into him, and an unbelievable, I mean, the New York Times, now so pious, Tom, attacked him for his flamboyant,
对。但也许它们变得重要是因为人们需要一个戏剧性的起点，来开启70年代中期真正开始流行的事情。没错。没错。所以我认为有一种明确的感觉，即70年代初社会格局正在发生变化。美国第一个真正的大型真人秀节目《美国家庭》，摄像机跟踪记录了一个特定的家庭，家庭中一个叫兰斯的儿子在节目中出柜了，这是1973年。如果他在十年前这样做，那对他来说就完了。他会被彻底毁掉。事实上，当时《纽约时报》的评论员对他进行了抨击，令人难以置信，我的意思是，《纽约时报》现在如此虔诚，汤姆，却攻击他那浮夸的、
leech-like homosexuality, called him a Goya-esque emotional dwarf. But actually, the New York Times got loads of grief for that. People said, come on, that's very harsh. Because he becomes a much-loved reality show character, doesn't he? He does. What's his name? Lance. I can't remember what his surname was. Anyway, who cares? He's called Lance anyway. I'm sure he does. So apologies if he's listening in on this. Yeah, he does. And lots of people listen to this too, and they will Google it, which is great. It's lovely. Yeah, true. Because we like people to be active while they listen to the, which is great. It's lovely. Yeah, true. Because, yeah, we like people to be active while they listen to the rest of history.
像水蛭一样的同性恋行为，称他为戈雅式的“情感侏儒”。但实际上，《纽约时报》因此受到了很多指责。人们说，得了吧，这太刻薄了。因为他成了一个备受喜爱的真人秀角色，不是吗？是的。他叫什么名字？兰斯。我不记得他的姓是什么了。不管怎样，谁在乎呢？反正他叫兰斯。我相信他确实是。所以如果他在听这个节目，我表示歉意。是的，他确实是。而且很多人也在听这个节目，他们会去谷歌搜索，这很棒。这很可爱。是的，真的。因为我们喜欢人们在听的时候保持活跃，这很棒。这很可爱。是的，真的。因为，是的，我们喜欢人们在听《历史的其余部分》时保持活跃。
So, Dominic, this is all happening, kind of, we've looked at New York so far. Yeah. But the city that is famously associated with gay rights, as well as New York, is San Francisco. Yeah. So San Francisco, it's interesting, actually. San Francisco is where you get a disco look,
所以，多米尼克，这一切都在发生，我们目前只看了纽约。是的。但除了纽约之外，与同性恋权利有着著名联系的城市是旧金山。是的。所以旧金山，这很有趣，实际上。旧金山是你获得迪斯科外观的地方，
but not the sound, I would say. So in San Francisco, there's a gay scene that develops there in the late 60s and 1970s that is arguably the most visible in the world, in particular in a part of San Francisco called the Castro. So that is where Armistead Maupin lives. Yeah. Who writes about Tales of the City. Yeah, absolutely.
但我认为不是那种声音。所以在旧金山，60年代末和70年代发展起来的同性恋场景可以说是世界上最显眼的，特别是在旧金山一个叫卡斯特罗的地区。所以那就是阿米斯特德·莫平住的地方。是的。他写了《城市故事》。是的，绝对是。
So it's in the Castro. There's actually a really really brilliant essay about it by the journalist Francis Fitzgerald who won basically every prize going in non-fiction America for her Vietnam war reporting and she wrote a brilliant essay about going to the Castro and what it was like because she writes about almost anthropologically like it's it's extraordinary that there's this kind of visible gay neighborhood. And she draws attention to the look because she's kind of struck by it. She doesn't take it for granted as we would. Basically dressing with very tight blue jeans, lumberjack shirt, leather jacket.
所以它在卡斯特罗。实际上有一篇关于它的非常非常精彩的文章，作者是记者弗朗西斯·菲茨杰拉德，她凭借越南战争报道获得了美国非虚构类作品的所有奖项。她写了一篇关于去卡斯特罗的精彩文章，描述了那里的情况，因为她几乎是从人类学的角度来写的，就像有一个可见的同性恋社区，这太不寻常了。她引起了人们对这种外观的注意，因为她被它震撼了。她不像我们那样认为这是理所当然的。基本上是穿着非常紧身的蓝色牛仔裤、伐木工衬衫、皮夹克。
Tom of Finland. Yeah. The kind of village people look. The moustache, the tight white t-shirt, all of that stuff. That look is being pioneered in san francisco and then it's beginning to spread well it's promoted by french producers isn't it village people yeah but it's a parody so it's a kind of commodification yeah it's a parody of it yeah so that style starts in san francisco and then it's copied in new york i would say so by the
芬兰的汤姆。是的。那种“乡村人”乐队的造型。胡子，紧身白T恤，所有这些东西。那种造型是在旧金山开创的，然后开始传播。嗯，它是被法国制作人推广的，不是吗？乡村人乐队。是的，但那是一种模仿，所以这是一种商品化。是的，这是对它的模仿。是的，所以那种风格始于旧金山，然后被纽约复制，我想是这样。所以到了
time disco comes into the mainstream which is about about 1974, 75, there is a much more assertive, visible gay community in New York. And disco is seen as an absolute part of that scene. So I'll just read you a radical journalist called Andrew Kopkin's rate at the end of the 70s. He said, disco is the background music for the shops, the bars and the restaurants and the offices where gays go about their business it is music for sex for dancing and for watching the straight world go by it is reassuring and supportive in an important way it is the sensational glue that unites a community
迪斯科进入主流的时候，大约是1974、75年，纽约有一个更加自信、显眼的同性恋社区。而迪斯科被视为那个场景中绝对的一部分。所以我给你读一下70年代末激进记者安德鲁·科普金的评价。他说，迪斯科是商店、酒吧、餐馆和办公室的背景音乐，同性恋者在那里处理他们的事务。它是用于性、跳舞和观看异性恋世界流逝的音乐。它以一种重要的方式令人安心和支持，它是团结社区的轰动性粘合剂。
but of course two things are happening by this point as with all subcultures and whether it be you know think about the teddy boys or mod in britain a few years after its emergence it starts to go mainstream and then people are complaining that it's lost its meaning so that's one thing and the second thing that happens particularly to disco is an extremely aggressive backlash and that's what we'll be coming to in the second half we'll see you in a few minutes. Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Hello, welcome back to The Rest Is History and we're looking at disco and Dominic, you left us with disco going mainstream and perhaps nothing illustrates just how mainstream than the fact that the portable peach mobile disco outfit was invited from Atlanta to Washington for Jimmy Carter's inaugural celebrations. Jimmy Carter, very pious Methodist who wore knitwear. Yeah. Cardigan
但当然，到这个时候有两件事正在发生，就像所有的亚文化一样，无论是泰迪男孩还是英国的摩登族，在它出现几年后，它开始走向主流，然后人们抱怨它失去了意义。所以这是一件事。第二件事，特别是对迪斯科而言，是一场极其激烈的反弹，这就是我们下半场要讲的内容，几分钟后再见。会员俱乐部。如果你想收听无广告内容、额外剧集并提前获得现场门票，请前往therestisentertainment.com。那是therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到《历史的其余部分》，我们正在研究迪斯科。多米尼克，你让我们停留在迪斯科走向主流的地方，也许没有什么比“便携式桃子移动迪斯科”团队被邀请从亚特兰大前往华盛顿参加吉米·卡特的就职典礼更能说明它有多主流了。吉米·卡特，非常虔诚的卫理公会教徒，穿着针织衫。是的。开衫
wearing. I mean, he's the least disco man I can think of. That's right. Disco dancers. So Jimmy Carter, of course, was a former peanut farmer, Tom. Yeah. And they had disco dancers in peanut costumes dancing to the music of the Bicentennial Disco Mix. Yeah. It sounds absolutely chilling. Well, it's quite royal jubilee, isn't it? I mean, we're in no position to throw stones at that one.
穿着者。我的意思是，他是我能想到的最不迪斯科的人。没错。迪斯科舞者。所以吉米·卡特当然是前花生农场主，汤姆。是的。他们有穿着花生服装的迪斯科舞者，随着“两百周年迪斯科混音”的音乐跳舞。是的。听起来绝对令人不寒而栗。嗯，这很像皇家禧年，不是吗？我的意思是，我们没有立场去指责那个。
It totally is. So this genre of music that, as we described in the first half, had begun in these kind of lofts and in these kind of grimy clubs in Hell's Kitchen in Manhattan, has gone mainstream by 1977 and has been stripped. Of everything that made it, yeah, subversive. Yeah, everything that made it vaguely cool. But against that, could we just look at probably the most famous cultural product
确实如此。所以这种音乐流派，正如我们在上半场描述的那样，始于曼哈顿地狱厨房的那些阁楼和肮脏的俱乐部，到1977年已经走向主流，并被剥离了。所有让它变得——是的，颠覆性的东西。是的，所有让它稍微显得酷的东西。但与之相对，我们能否看看可能最著名的文化产品
that emerges from disco, which is Saturday Night Fever? Yeah. Absolutely massive film, the making of John Travolta. Now, I was stunned to learn that it's based on a piece of journalism by a British journalist who'd completely made it up. And actually, what seems to be a film about Brooklyn is actually a film about Shepard's Bush in London. That's right.
从迪斯科中产生，那就是《周末夜狂热》？是的。绝对巨大的电影，约翰·特拉沃尔塔的成名作。现在，我震惊地得知它是基于一位英国记者完全编造的新闻报道。事实上，看起来是一部关于布鲁克林的电影，实际上是一部关于伦敦谢泼德丛林的电影。没错。
I love this fact. So can you tease that out for the listeners? So in 1977, disco had really gone mainstream. There were lots of big hits. So I Feel Love, Donna Summer's hit. That's 1977 and that december saturday night fever comes out it's by far the biggest film in the holiday season in america the only rival to it is star wars and it's been inspired by an article in new york magazine a
我喜欢这个事实。所以你能为听众揭开这个谜吗？所以到了1977年，迪斯科确实已经走向主流。有很多大热歌曲。比如《我感受到了爱》，唐娜·萨默的热门歌曲。那是1977年，同年12月《周末夜狂热》上映，它是美国假日季节最大的电影，唯一的竞争对手是《星球大战》。它的灵感来自于《纽约杂志》上的一篇文章，
year earlier by the british pop journalist nick cohen and he's gone over to America for the first time. He's been doing loads of stuff in British rock magazines and stuff. And disco has gone out beyond this very, very urban heartland. And it's gone into the suburbs. And now there are lots of disco clubs springing up in the kind of suburbs of New York. And the people who are frequenting it are very different from the original, you know, the peace activists and the gay rights are frequenting it are very different from the original,
一年前由英国流行音乐记者尼克·科恩撰写。他第一次去美国。他一直在英国摇滚杂志上做很多事情。迪斯科已经超出了这个非常、非常城市化的中心地带。它已经进入了郊区。现在纽约的郊区涌现出很多迪斯科俱乐部。而经常光顾那里的人与最初的，你知道，和平活动家和同性恋权利活动家，与最初的，
you know, the peace activists and the gay rights activists and whatnot of the original kind of 1970, 1971 clubs. These are lower middle class, working class kids, white kids, often of Italian or Eastern European heritage. The people who live in these kind of Brooklyn suburbs. So hence John Travolta. Hence John Travolta. European heritage. The people who live in these kind of Brooklyn suburbs. So hence John Travolta. Hence John Travolta. His character is Tony Manero, I think his name is.
你知道，1970、1971年俱乐部的和平活动家和同性恋权利活动家等等非常不同。这些是下中产阶级、工人阶级的孩子，白人孩子，通常是意大利或东欧血统。住在这些布鲁克林郊区的人。所以这就是约翰·特拉沃尔塔。这就是约翰·特拉沃尔塔。欧洲血统。住在这些布鲁克林郊区的人。所以这就是约翰·特拉沃尔塔。这就是约翰·特拉沃尔塔。他的角色是托尼·马内罗，我想是这个名字。
So Nick Cohen goes out to these Brooklyn places or whatever, and he just thinks, I'm totally out of my depth here. I don't know what's going on. So he writes the story, and he writes it about a guy, and he says there's a guy called Vincent. But he's basically made Vincent up, and he's based him on a mod that he knew in Shepherd's Bush, a one-time king of Goldhawk Road, as he later admitted. And basically nobody follows this up at all.
所以尼克·科恩去了这些布鲁克林的地方，他只是想，我在这里完全不知所措。我不知道发生了什么。所以他写了这个故事，他写了一个叫文森特的人。但他基本上是编造了文森特，他把他基于他在谢泼德丛林认识的一个摩登族，正如他后来承认的那样，曾经是高鹰路的国王。基本上没有人去核实这一点。
People just say, oh, this is an absolutely brilliant story. Love it. Let's make a film of it. So the whole thing is basically a story about mods in the 60s, but dressed up in sort of 70s paraphernalia. And actually, if you watch Saturday Night Fever now, the thing about it is it's so gritty. Yeah, it is. And it's a really kind of brutal film, really. Yeah.
人们只是说，哦，这是一个绝对精彩的故事。喜欢它。让我们把它拍成电影吧。所以整个事情基本上是一个关于60年代摩登族的故事，但穿上了70年代的行头。事实上，如果你现在看《周末夜狂热》，它的特点是它非常坚韧。是的，它是。这确实是一部非常残酷的电影。是的。
There's a rape scene. There's lots of violence. Kind of suicide. Everybody's poor and alienated. And they're dancing to escape. Yeah. They're dancing to escape the kind of grittiness so that's obviously part of disco's enduring appeal so on the one hand you have the dancing
有一个强奸场景。有很多暴力。某种自杀。每个人都很穷且被疏远。他们跳舞是为了逃避。是的。他们跳舞是为了逃避那种坚韧，所以这显然是迪斯科持久吸引力的一部分。所以一方面你有跳舞
to escape you have disco as escapism and the other you have disco as excess and that's represented also in 1977 by studio 54 right so this is the one where mick jagger isn't allowed in yeah so the whole issue whether you're allowed in or not. Bianca Jagger famously is photographed going in on a white horse for her birthday. Yeah. When I dug into this, she published a very anguished article quite recently in The Guardian in which she said, listen, I did not ride that horse into the club because I'm an animal rights lover. The horse was already in the club and I allowed myself to be photographed astride it. So what was the horse doing in the club because I'm an animal rights lover. The horse was already in the club and I allowed myself to be photographed to stride it.
为了逃避，你有作为逃避主义的迪斯科，另一方面你有作为过度的迪斯科，这在1977年也由54俱乐部代表，对吧？所以这就是米克·贾格尔不被允许进入的那一个。是的，所以整个问题在于你是否被允许进入。比安卡·贾格尔因在生日那天骑着白马进入俱乐部而被拍照而闻名。是的。当我深入研究这个时，她最近在《卫报》上发表了一篇非常痛苦的文章，她说，听着，我并没有骑那匹马进入俱乐部，因为我是一个动物权利爱好者。那匹马已经在俱乐部里了，我只是允许自己被拍到骑在它上面。那么那匹马在俱乐部里做什么？因为我是一个动物权利爱好者。那匹马已经在俱乐部里了，我允许自己被拍到骑在它上面。
So what was the horse doing in the club? If there's ever a club that was going to have a horse in, it was Studio 54. It's all totally over the top. It's kind of groovy. Do you know who went on the opening night, Tom? Sylvester Stallone. Yeah, but not just Sylvester Stallone.
那么那匹马在俱乐部里做什么？如果有一个俱乐部会有一匹马，那就是54俱乐部。这一切都完全过火了。这很时髦。你知道开幕之夜谁去了吗，汤姆？西尔维斯特·史泰龙。是的，但不仅仅是西尔维斯特·史泰龙。
A then obscure property developer called Donald Trump. So Mick Jagger wasn't allowed in, but Donald Trump was. Yeah. Okay. So this kind of sums up how disco perhaps, you know, it's reaching its peak and threatening a kind of over ripeness that might spell collapse. So you've got that.
一个当时默默无闻的房地产开发商，名叫唐纳德·特朗普。所以米克·贾格尔不被允许进入，但唐纳德·特朗普却进去了。是的。好吧。所以这总结了迪斯科也许，你知道，它正在达到顶峰，并威胁到一种可能预示崩溃的过度成熟。所以你有那个。
You've got kind of parody acts like the village people right so the produce people or bony m or bony m we think of them most people i guess say oh they haven't mentioned the village people of bony m that's because they're not kind of disco as cool what they are is disco as just a dressed up novelty record as a joke novelty record so you know rasputin or ymca they are parodies of disco really rather than the original the donna summer gloria gainer kind of disco at its peak of innovation as it were but that's obviously now what we think but of course to the original disco progenitors the village people or or rod stewart doing disco tom do you think i'm sexy and that's not a question i'm that's the name of the no i i understand we would only answer
你有像乡村人乐队这样的模仿行为，对吧？所以制作人，或者波尼M乐队，或者波尼M乐队，我们认为他们，我想大多数人会说，哦，他们没有提到乡村人乐队或波尼M乐队，那是因为他们不是那种酷的迪斯科，他们是作为一种装扮的噱头唱片，作为一种笑话噱头唱片。所以你知道《拉斯普京》或《YMCA》，它们实际上是对迪斯科的模仿，而不是最初的唐娜·萨默、格洛丽亚·盖纳那种处于创新巅峰的迪斯科。但那显然是我们现在的想法，但当然，对于最初的迪斯科先驱来说，乡村人乐队或者罗德·斯图尔特做迪斯科，汤姆，你认为我很性感，这不是一个问题，我是说那是那个的名字，不，我理解，我们只会回答
that question on a bonus episode for our rest of history club members so chic le freak yeah le freak they were originally called alla and the knife wielding punks that's a good name yeah that's a much better name. But punk is starting to come at this point, isn't it? It is, yeah. As a kind of reaction mainly to prog rock, but also to disco. And the whole point of that is that it's pared back, simple. Exactly. So there've always been people who are very suspicious of disco. So indeed, people among the original kind of, what you might think of as this kind of demographic heartland at the beginning of the 70s, which is kind of people who are keen to preserve the spirit of the 60s.
那个问题在给我们的“历史的其余部分”俱乐部成员的额外剧集中。所以Chic乐队的《Le Freak》，是的，《Le Freak》，他们最初叫Alla和挥舞刀子的朋克，那是个好名字。是的，那是个好得多的名字。但朋克在这一点上开始出现了，不是吗？是的，确实。主要是作为对前卫摇滚的一种反应，但也针对迪斯科。而这一切的重点是它被削减了，简单。没错。所以一直有人对迪斯科非常怀疑。事实上，在70年代初，你可能认为属于这种人口中心地带的人中，也就是那些热衷于保持60年代精神的人。
And these people would say there's always this suspicion that disco is, and I quote, unreal, artificially exaggerated, stylish, sleek, smooth, contrived and controlled. Disco places surface over substance, mood over meaning, action over thought. And there's a guy called Albert Goldman. He wrote a biography of John Lennon, very controversial. Yes, scabrous biography. And he said in 1978, the real thrust of disco culture is not towards love of another person, but it's towards love of self. Outside the entrance to every discotheque should be erected a statue of the presiding deity, Narcissus.
这些人会说，一直有一种怀疑，认为迪斯科是，我引用一下，“不真实的、人为夸大的、时髦的、圆滑的、平滑的、做作的和受控的”。迪斯科将表面置于实质之上，将情绪置于意义之上，将行动置于思想之上。有一个叫阿尔伯特·戈德曼的人。他写了一本约翰·列侬的传记，非常有争议。是的，粗俗的传记。他在1978年说，迪斯科文化的真正推动力不是对另一个人的爱，而是对自我的爱。在每个迪斯科舞厅的入口处都应该竖立一座主宰神纳西索斯的雕像。
Is this homophobic? Is this a way of dressing up criticism of gay culture as a criticism of disco? No, I don't think this is. I think this is actually a not wholly illegitimate criticism. So if you look at something like Studio 54, that feels like it really anticipates some of the excess, the commercialism, the worship of celebrity, the showiness, the sensationalism of the 80s i would say so hence the presence of donald trump has the presence of donald trump and white horses yeah and i think there is an element of there are people who remember the 60s who feel that what has actually happened in the 70s is that coolness counterculture all of that stuff, nightlife, bohemianism, that it has lost any
这是恐同吗？这是一种将对同性恋文化的批评伪装成对迪斯科的批评的方式吗？不，我不认为这是。我认为这实际上是一个并非完全不合理的批评。所以如果你看看像54俱乐部这样的地方，那感觉确实预示了一些80年代的过度、商业主义、对名人的崇拜、炫耀、耸人听闻，我会这么说。所以这就是唐纳德·特朗普在场的原因，唐纳德·特朗普在场和白马。是的，我认为有一个因素是，有些人记得60年代，他们觉得70年代真正发生的事情是，酷、反文化、所有这些东西、夜生活、波西米亚主义，它已经失去了任何
of its political edge that it had back in 1967, 68. And that actually we've lost all sense of idealism and it's just pure hedonism and that that's not right. But there are criticisms of disco from the right, yeah? Undoubtedly. Undoubtedly. Yes. Which are essentially that, you know know it's a load of gay people taking over music and it shouldn't be allowed totally so here's the thing rock music there had always been a kind of sexually subversive element i guess to popular music and that goes right back way beyond the birth of recorded music i mean that goes back to musicals of
它在1967、68年拥有的政治优势。实际上我们已经失去了所有的理想主义，这纯粹是享乐主义，这不对。但从右翼对迪斯科有批评，对吧？毫无疑问。毫无疑问。是的。本质上是，你知道，这是一群同性恋者接管了音乐，这不应该被允许。完全正确。所以这就是重点，摇滚乐，一直有一种性颠覆的元素，我想，在流行音乐中，这可以追溯到录音音乐诞生之前，我的意思是，这可以追溯到杂耍表演的音乐剧或类似的东西，但不要陷入那种文化研究的术语中，但很多摇滚乐一直是以一种非常男性化的异性恋方式编码的，不是吗？我的意思是，你想到齐柏林飞艇那种，布鲁斯·斯普林斯汀那种，我想，大头发，汗流浃背，很多骨肉皮，你知道，吉他上的阳具崇拜，所有这些东西。显然有很多白人孩子喜欢那个。他们喜欢它非常白，非常汗流浃背和具有侵略性，女性在歌词中被商品化和抛弃，所有这些事情。他们对迪斯科的同性恋感到不安，因为有黑人女性
vaudeville or something but not to get too bogged down in kind of cultural studies jargon but a lot of kind of rock had been as it were coded in a very masculine heterosexual way hadn't i mean you think of the kind of the led zeppelin kind of bruce springsteen i guess big hair sweaty loads of groupies you know the phallic stuff with the guitar, all of that kind of thing. And there's obviously a lot of white kids who love that. They like the fact that it's very white, that it's very sweaty and aggressive, and that women are kind of commodified and cast aside in the lyrics and all that thing. And they're unsettled by disco's gayness, by the fact that there are black women
如此突出，以至于它将女性化视为一种美德，所有这些东西。如果我们只关注一个特定的人物，有一个叫史蒂夫·达尔的人。我们很多美国听众可能听说过他的名字。他是一个冲击广播员，一个典型的冲击广播员。1978年平安夜，他被解雇了，在
that are so prominent that it makes a virtue of effeminacy, of all that kind of thing. And if we just focus on one particular character, so there's a guy called Steve Dahl. So many of our American listeners may have heard his name. He is a shock jock, a prototypical shock jock. And on Christmas Eve in 1978, he was sacked from his job at a
芝加哥一个叫WDAI的电台，因为他们想从摇滚转向迪斯科。所以他被踢出去了。是的。他24岁，搬到了一个竞争对手电台。但当他搬到竞争对手电台时，为了报复，他发起了“迪斯科去死”运动。他做了一些事情，比如，他搞了一些噱头，比如他冲击了一个青少年的迪斯科舞厅。在范·麦考伊，那个做《The Hustle》的人，在范·麦考伊死于心脏病的那天，他仪式性地销毁了一张《The Hustle》的唱片。哦，那是一种深思熟虑的方式。这很糟糕，汤姆，这是非常糟糕的行为。还有其他人像他一样。他是那个在棒球比赛中砸碎迪斯科的人吗？是的，我们会讲到这个。所以到这一点，有一种砸碎迪斯科的时尚
Chicago station called WDAI because they wanted to switch from rock to disco. So he's booted out. Yeah. He's 24 years old and he moves to a rival station. But when he moves to the rival station, in revenge, he launches the Disco Sucks campaign. And he does things like, he does stunts, like he storms a disco for teenagers. On the day that a guy called Van McCoy, the guy, The Hustle, on the day that Van McCoy died of a heart attack, he ritually destroyed a copy of the hustle of his record oh that's a thoughtful way of it's poor form tom it's very bad very bad behavior and there are other people like him is he the guy who does the smashing up of disco demolition yeah at a baseball match we'll come on to this so by this point there is a vogue for smashing up disco
唱片。所以有一个圣何塞的迪斯科广播员。他自称叫丹尼斯·埃雷克图斯。他有一个节目叫“埃雷克图斯摧毁唱片”，他会播放一首歌的前几小节，然后他会销毁唱片，他会播放人们呕吐的声音，那将是迪斯科唱片。有一个叫疯狂达伦·韦恩的人，他在沙子里埋葬迪斯科专辑。
records so there's a san jose disc jockey. He purports to be called Dennis Erectus. And he has a show called Erectus Wrecks a Record where he will play the first few bars of a song and then he'll destroy the record and he'll have the sound of people vomiting over it and it'll be disco records. There's a guy called Insane Darren Wayne who buries disco albums in the sand.
在密歇根州，有“底特律摇滚乐手参与废除迪斯科”，他们被称为DREAD，他们到处砸碎迪斯科唱片。我的意思是，对一种音乐形式如此强烈地反对似乎很奇怪。当然。但为什么人们要这样做？所以史蒂夫·达尔和他的新广播电台WLUP从一家咨询公司那里得到了建议。这些顾问，伯克哈特·艾布拉姆斯联合公司，对15到25岁的年轻人进行了一项调查。他们发现这些人认为迪斯科是，我引用一下，“肤浅的、无聊的、重复的”，引用结束，“没有胆量”。他们被这种生活方式吓到了，部分是因为它强调身体和服装的完美，部分是因为它的气氛如此
In Michigan, there's the Detroit Rockers Engaged in the Abolition of Disco who are called Dread, and they go around smashing up disco records. I mean, this seems quite odd to be that violently opposed to a form of music. Of course. But why are people doing it? So Steve Dahl and his new radio station, WLUP, had taken advice from a firm of consultants. And these consultants, Burkhardt Abrams Associates, had done a survey of young people between the ages of 15 and 25. And they found that these people thought that disco was, and I quote, superficial, boring, repetitive, and quote, short on balls. They're intimidated by the lifestyle, partly on its emphasis on physical and sartorial perfection, partly because its atmosphere is so
充满了性。他们觉得它是，“同性恋者的音乐”。它没有胆量。它是黑人和同性恋的。所以我们处于70年代末的美国。那是卡特时代。越南战争已经失败了。总统穿着开衫，为了节省电力关掉了所有的灯，被兔子攻击，被杀手兔攻击，完全正确。所以有一种感觉，汤姆，说美国男性气概受到攻击、处于危机之中，并且有一代白人蓝领，也许是孩子、男孩讨厌这种东西，这太强烈了吗？他们认为迪斯科在某种模糊的方式下，与他们面临的所有羞辱纠缠在一起
charged with sex. They feel that it is, quote, music for gay people. It hasn't got balls. It's black and gay. So we're in late 70s America. It's the Carter years. The Vietnam War has been lost. The president wears a cardigan and is turning all the lights off to save electricity being attacked by rabbits and being attacked by a killer rabbit exactly so there is a sense that is it too strong tom to say that american masculinity is under attack is in crisis and that there are a generation of white kind of blue collar, maybe kids, boys who hate this kind of thing. And they see disco is somehow in some obscure way, wrapped up with all the humiliations
在其他领域。我不认为这太强烈了。而且我认为肯定有一个因素，比如反沿海精英，反富有的自由派在54俱乐部吸食可卡因，反黑人，反同性恋。我认为这一切都包含在其中。是的。好吧，所以我再次引用鲍勃·斯坦利的话。他说，
that they are facing in other spheres. I don't think that's too strong. And I think there's definitely an element of like anti-coastal elites, anti-rich liberals taking cocaine at Studio 54, anti-black, anti-gay. I think this is all wrapped up in it. Yeah. Well, so I'm quoting Bob Stanley again. He says,
迪斯科最终比任何其他主要的流行趋势跌落得更猛烈、更快。是的。这太不寻常了。而你已经提到的那一刻，总结这一切的那一刻是1979年7月12日的“迪斯科拆除德比”，或者我们的美国听众无疑会说，德比。
Disco eventually fell harder and faster than any other major pop trend. Yeah. And it's extraordinary. And the moment that, you've mentioned it already, the moment that sums this up is the Disco Demolition Derby, or our American listeners would say, no doubt, Derby, on the 12th of July, 1979.
所以这是芝加哥白袜队。所以有趣的是它在芝加哥，一个中心地带城市，而不是沿海城市。芝加哥白袜队很烂。他们状态极差，他们有一场对阵底特律老虎队的双重赛。基本上，为了招揽生意，他们的促销经理说，任何带一张迪斯科唱片来销毁的球迷都可以以98美分的低价入场。而史蒂夫·达尔将负责这个，这个“迪斯科去死”的家伙。所以他在他的节目中推广它，他将负责销毁唱片。5万人出现了，汤姆，
So what this is, the Chicago White Sox. So it's interesting that it's in Chicago, a kind of heartland city, not a coastal city. Chicago White Sox are rubbish. They're in terrible form, and they've got a double header game against the Detroit Tigers. And basically, to drum up custom, their promotions manager says, any fan who brings a disco record to be destroyed will get in for a cheap rate for 98 cents. And Steve Dahl is going to take charge of this, this Disco Sucks guy. So he promotes it on his show and he's going to be in charge of destroying the records. 50,000 people turned up, Tom,
带着票，包括数千名没有票的人。他们中的许多人喝得烂醉或吸毒。是的。所以他们冲破了
with tickets, including thousands more without tickets. And many of them are absolutely hammered on drink or drugs. Yeah. So they sort of storm
检票口。他们进入了体育场。白袜队打了第一场比赛，他们输了。他们被底特律老虎队羞辱了。然后是销毁迪斯科唱片的插曲。人群要疯了。5万人敲打着，他们高呼，
the turnstiles. They get into the stadium. The Right Sox play their first game and they lose. They're humiliated by the Detroit Tigers. Then there's the interlude with the destruction of the disco records. The crowd's going to go berserk. 50,000 people banging and they're chanting,
“迪斯科去死”。史蒂夫·达尔上场了，他穿着军装和头盔。他有一个装有1万张唱片的箱子，他引爆了它。我看过视频片段。是的，芝加哥白袜队显然没有同意这一点，或者沟通出现了故障，因为它在球场上炸出了一个洞。是的，那不好，不是吗？到处都是迪斯科唱片的残骸，在那一刻，一半的人群发疯了，入侵了球场，开始纵火，拆毁体育场的部分设施等等。
Disco sucks. Steve Dahl comes on and he's dressed in military fatigues and a helmet. And he has a box with 10,000 which he detonates i've seen the video footage yeah and the chicago white socks clearly had not agreed to this or there's been some communications breakdown because it blows a hole in the field yeah that's not good is it and there's like remains of disco records everywhere and at that point half the crowd goes berserk and invades the pitch starting fires, demolishing bits of the stadium and stuff.
最终，防暴警察不得不清理体育场。现在，不用说，他们没能打第二场比赛。他们没收了第二场比赛。并不是说他们本来会赢。不。显然，这不是迪斯科失宠的原因。但那一刻……不，这是一个症状，而不是原因。
And eventually, riot police have to clear the stadium. Now, needless to say, they don't get to play that second game. They forfeit the second game. Not that they were going to win it anyway. No. Obviously, that's not why Disco fell from grace. But that moment... No, it's a symptom, not a cause.
是的，那成为迪斯科失宠的象征性时刻。因为实际上，那是一个症状，而不是原因。是的，那成为迪斯科失宠的象征性时刻。因为实际上，那是1979年中期。到了1979年秋天，迪斯科已经完全从美国单曲榜上消失了。关于这一点有趣且有点奇怪的是，正是从芝加哥，浩室音乐将会出现。而浩室音乐将支撑90年代舞蹈文化和俱乐部活动的复兴。现在这会让我们的听众或其中一些人感到惊讶，但你是历史界的迈克尔·戈夫，不是吗？谢谢，因为英国内阁大臣迈克尔·戈夫以热爱跳舞而闻名，他会穿着西装去阿伯丁或什么地方独自去俱乐部。而你也是浩室音乐的忠实爱好者，不是吗？嗯，我曾经是。现在不是了。我记得在凯蒂出生大约三周后，我的大女儿，我去了，我度过了一段美好的时光。然后我想，这太不体面了。从这一点开始，我要按照我的年龄应有的方式行事。哦，真的吗？这是一个我一直坚持的誓言。
Yeah, that becomes the symbolic moment when Disco falls from grace. Because actually, that's a symptom, not a cause. Yeah. That becomes the symbolic moment when disco falls to grace. Because actually, that's the middle of 1979. By the autumn of 1979, disco has totally vanished from the US singles chart. What's interesting about that, and a bit odd, is that it is from Chicago that house music will emerge. And house music will underpin the revival revival of dance culture and and clubbing in the 90s now this will amaze our listeners or some of them but you are the michael gove of
天哪。是的。所以这对人们来说是一种激励。如果你成为“历史的其余部分”的埃塞尔斯坦，也就是我们的精英会员，也许你可以说服汤姆在夜总会举行我们的埃塞尔斯坦聚会。好吧，所以布里克斯顿有一个叫“冰箱”的俱乐部。冰箱。他们有一个叫“爱之肌肉”的环节。
history aren't you thank you because michael gove the british cabinet minister is famous for his love of dancing and he will go to Aberdeen or something in his suit and go clubbing on his own. And you too are a great lover of house music, are you not? Well, I was. Not now. I remember about three weeks after Katie was born, my oldest daughter, and I went and I just had a brilliant time. Then I thought, this is so undignified. From this point on, I'm going to behave as I should according to my age. Oh, really? And that is a vow I have always stuck to.
爱之肌肉。是的，这很迪斯科，不是吗？美好的日子。这很公平。是的。所以我认为发生的事情是，在70年代末，迪斯科失宠的原因之一仅仅是代际更替。
Oh, my word. Yes. So there's an incentive for people. If you become an Athelstan of the rest of history, so our elite members, maybe you can persuade Tom to hold one of our Athelstan get togethers in a nightclub. Well, so there was a club in Brixton called The Fridge. The Fridge. And they had a session called Love Muscle.
所以如果你在1970年20岁，你是汤姆·霍兰德。你在1980年30岁，你想做一些更体面的事情。你太老了，不适合它。你知道，你有孩子，所有这些事情。但当然，如果你在1980年20岁，你不想听爷爷的迪斯科，不，你想要一些新的东西，不是吗？所以这是一个因素。是的，麦当娜。我还认为有一件更深层的事情，那就是在70年代末，普遍存在着对同性恋权利和对70年代所谓的“烫发”的反弹，普遍存在着对同性恋权利的反弹
Love Muscle. Yeah, it's quite disco, isn't it? Great days. That's fair. Yeah. So I think what's happened is that at the end of the 1970s, one of the reasons that disco falls from grace is simply generational turnover.
以及对所谓的“放任自由主义”的反弹。有很多例子。但多米尼克，我的意思是，这当然与袭击美国乃至全世界同性恋社区的巨大灾难有关。艾滋病。是的。是的，当然。我认为在某种意义上，关于反弹，已经有一些人，政治家。所以最著名的是佛罗里达州的一位女性，名叫安妮塔·布莱恩特，她是一位推广橙汁的歌手。她在1977年发起了一场名为“拯救我们的孩子”的运动，并因此受到了很多关注。一年后，加利福尼亚州确实有一个名为“布里格斯倡议”的公投。同样，所有这些关于拯救孩子的事情。
So if you're 20 in 1970, you're Tom Holland. You're 30 in 1980, and you want to do something a bit more dignified. You're too old for it. You know, you've got kids, all of that kind of thing. But also, of course, if you're 20 in 1980 and you want to do something a bit more dignified you're too old for it you know you've got kids all of that kind of thing but also of course if you're 20 in 1980 you don't want to listen to granddad's disco no you want something new don't you so that's an element of it yeah madonna i also think there is a deeper thing which is that at the end of the 1970s there is generally a backlash against gay rights and against what's seen as the perm of the 1970s, there is generally a backlash against gay rights
所以有很多那样的东西。然后有很多关于所谓的“不健康”的事情。这包括来自同性恋社区内部。人们谈论纽约这些俱乐部的“不健康”，俱乐部有着稍微令人不安的名字，Ramrod、Mine Shaft、Cock Ring，但这些大概更多的是性在那些俱乐部中被置于前景，而不是音乐。Mine Shaft，是的，一位评论家称它为“一部分是色情天堂，一部分是开放的伤口”，另一个人称它为“污秽的拉什莫尔山”，你可以发挥自己的想象力。
and against what's seen as the permissive liberalism. And there are lots of examples of that. But also, Dominic, I mean, that is tied in with, of course, the great calamity that hits gay community in the United States and then around the world. AIDS. Yeah. Yes, of course. And I think there's a sense in which, so just on the backlash, there have been people, politicians. So the most famous one is a woman in Florida called Anita Bryant, who was a singer who had promoted orange juice. And she launched a campaign called Save Our Children and gets loads of attention for it in 1977. And there was indeed, there was a referendum called the Briggs Initiative in California a year later. Again, all this stuff about saving children.
所以艾滋病来了，艾滋病的第一份报告，他们也许没有像应该的那样被认真对待的一个原因，是因为它们出现在关于性传播疾病、关于同性恋男性中肝炎、淋病感染等大规模激增的更广泛讨论的背景下。事实上，旧金山和纽约的公共卫生诊所到70年代末已经处于巨大争议的中心，因为他们有点在说“冷静点，慢下来，这太多了”，然后其他人说“哦，你太恐同了，你试图监管我们的生活方式”，所有这些事情。所以实际上，关于肺炎患者的第一份报告，他们需要时间才能意识到这是一种新的东西。是的，所以第一份报告，它在一份同性恋报纸《纽约本地人》上，1981年报道了关于一种奇异的新疾病的传言
So there's a lot of that. And then there's a lot of stuff about what's seen as the unhealthiness. This is including from within the gay community itself. People talking about the unhealthiness of these clubs in New York and stuff, clubs with slightly disconcerting names, the Ramrod mine shaft the cock ring but these presumably are more kind of the sex is foregrounded in those clubs rather than the music the mine shaft yeah one critic called it um one part erotic paradise one part open wound and somebody else called it the mount rushmore of filth which um you can use your own imagination.
袭击了纽约的同性恋社区。标题是“疾病传言基本无根据”，因为有一种可以理解的冲动，即说，“这只是又一个诽谤。这是又一次试图把我们关回盒子里，并将我们与不健康联系起来，这是我们不应得的。”不管怎样，在这种背景下，我认为你可能称之为70年代初更纯真的享乐主义，那种“爱拯救了一天，让我们都有一个美好的时光”，
So AIDS comes, the first reports of AIDS, one reason that they're perhaps not taken as seriously as they should have been, is because they come in the context of a wider discussion about sexually transmitted diseases, about massive surge in hepatitis, gonorrheainal infections and so on among gay men and actually the public health clinics in san francisco and new york are already at the center of big controversies at the end of the 70s because they are sort of saying calm down slow down there's too much of this and then other people are saying oh that's very homophobic of you you're trying to police our lifestyle and all of that kind of thing so actually the first reports of people with pneumonia it takes time for them to realize that it's something something new yeah so the very first report it's in a gay paper the new york native in 1981 reporting rumors that an exotic new disease
到70年代末和80年代初，那种光彩已经消失了，我会这么说。当然，我的意思是，你提到了浩室音乐，但显然是嘻哈。嘻哈也开始从布朗克斯这样的地方出现，而嘻哈很酷，迪斯科开始显得，部分是因为波尼M乐队和乡村人乐队的东西，是的，当然，它只是一个笑话，是的，它很傻
has hit the gay community in new y. The headline is disease rumors largely unfounded because there is a sort of an understandable impulse to say, you know, this is just yet another slur. This is yet another kind of attempt to put us back in our box and to identify us with unhealthiness, which we don't deserve. Anyway, so against that background, I think the sort of what you might call the more innocent hedonism of early 70s disco, the kind of love saves the day, let's all have a wonderful time,
以一种在1972年或73年不傻的方式，但那种欣快感的享乐主义确实回来了，完全是。是的，所以你知道它在循环，不是吗？这是音乐史上不变的东西，不是吗？对逃避主义、享乐主义、释放的渴望。有趣的是，作为一种非常个人化的自恋体验，你打扮自己并仅仅为自己跳舞，还是你这样做是为了与他人交流，这种张力如何？汤姆，当你去浩室俱乐部时，你是自恋者还是在交流？不，我是在与他人交流，因为这是可卡因和摇头丸之间的区别，不是吗？
that's kind of lost its luster, I would say, by the end of the 70s and by the early 1980s. And of course, I mean, you mentioned house music, but obviously hip hop. Hip hop is also beginning to emerge from places like the Bronx and it's hip hop that's cool and disco is beginning to seem partly because of the boney m stuff and the village people yeah of course it's just a bit of a joke yeah it's silly
对。好吧。我的意思是，我不是两者的狂热爱好者。但可卡因更多是关于自恋，而摇头丸众所周知是关于公共体验。所以这些毒品塑造了它们产生的舞蹈文化。它们绝对做到了。在那颗重磅炸弹上——多么重磅的炸弹。
in a way that it hadn't been silly in 1972 or 73 but that kind of euphoric feeling of hedonism does come back totally yeah so you know it goes in cycles doesn doesn't it? It's a constant, isn't it, in musical history? The desire for escapism, for hedonism, for release. The interesting thing is whether that tension between being a very individual narcissistic experience, you dressing up and dancing just for yourself, or are you doing it to commune with other people? Tom, when you were going to the house clubs, were you a narcissist or were you communing? No, I was communing with other people, because it's the difference between cocaine and ecstasy, isn't it?
以一种1972年或73年时并不显得愚蠢的方式，但那种享乐主义的狂喜感确实完全回归了，是的，所以你知道它是有周期的，不是吗？这在音乐史上是一个常数，对吧？对逃避现实、享乐主义和释放的渴望。有趣的是，这种张力究竟是源于一种非常个人化的自恋体验——你盛装打扮，只为自己跳舞，还是为了与他人交流？汤姆，当你去浩室俱乐部时，你是自恋的，还是在与人交流？不，我是在与他人交流，因为这就像可卡因和摇头丸之间的区别，不是吗？
Right. Okay. I mean, I'm not a massive enthusiast for either. But cocaine is more about narcissism and ecstasy famously is about the communal experience. And so those drugs shape the dance cultures that they generate. They definitely do. And on that bombshell- What a bombshell.
没错。好吧。我的意思是，我并不是这两者的狂热爱好者。但可卡因更多是关于自恋，而摇头丸众所周知是关于群体体验。因此，这些毒品塑造了它们所产生的舞蹈文化。它们确实如此。带着这个重磅炸弹——真是个重磅炸弹。
Thank you, Dominic. They definitely do. And on that bombshell. What a bombshell. Thank you, Dominic. DJ Dominic. Yeah. This is one of my deleted scenes from my book, Mad as Hell. Yeah, and you've left out quite a lot, haven't you? I have.
谢谢你，多米尼克。他们确实如此。带着这个重磅炸弹。真是个重磅炸弹。谢谢你，多米尼克。DJ多米尼克。是的。这是我书《Mad as Hell》中被删减的片段之一。是的，你删掉了很多内容，不是吗？是的。
There was a load more stuff about the mineshaft. Yeah. You plumb the depths. Yes, which people are probably happy to have been spared. You dig deep, but not on this podcast. But thank you very much.
关于矿井还有很多内容。是的。你深入挖掘了。是的，人们可能很高兴能免受其扰。你挖掘得很深，但在这个播客里没有。但非常感谢你。
Wonderful to see another chunk of your vanished masterpiece brought to light. All right. Bye-bye, everybody. See you next time. Bye-bye. I'm Marina Hyde and I'm Richard Osman and together we host The Rest Is Entertainment
很高兴看到你那部消失的杰作的另一部分重见天日。好了。再见，各位。下次见。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们共同主持《The Rest Is Entertainment》。
it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works
这是你们每周的娱乐新闻评论、一点演艺圈八卦，在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的幕布，告诉你们这一切是如何运作的。
we have just launched our members club if you want ad free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to therestisentertainment.com There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部，如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和提前购买现场演出门票，请访问therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。